and as we get ready to start the session
i'm going to be
starting our live stream
for our
linkedin and youtube viewers please bear
with me for a moment and then we will
begin
you could be on mute
oh
i am not
is that better
yeah
okay
so before we start i would like to
remind people how to use the webex
controls
the q a
boxes for your questions for
krishna and russell
and
we'll keep track of those for the
question and answer period at the end of
this panel
you can also enter comments into the
chat box and
russell and christian will be able to
see those
as i said
today's session is a panel discussion
corporate upskilling and reskilling
trends from 21
and strategies for the future
and
let's get started with a quick poll
of the audience
to give krishna and russell an idea
of who we're speaking to today
so
this first poll is two parts
what is your role in your organization
and the second part is
just the age of how you're doing today
we've been asking that during
the pandemic to make sure that
we have a feel for
how people are holding up under the
stress
and we'll give about another 20 seconds
we'll close the poll five seconds
three
two
one
all right
the largest cohorts
are other functional leader and learning
and development managers
um
some interesting representation for
marketing and sales
we also are glad to see that
everybody's doing at least
in the middle and
most of you are doing
well today so
with that let's move on to
introductions
panelists
kumar the ceo of simply learn and
russell kenrick managing director of
ilex
founded similar in 2010 it went from
being a blog on project management to
a worldwide
digital education company with three
million users and counting and he is an
acknowledged uh thought leader in
edutech
russ beats a portfolio of companies that
specialize in corporate training and
consulting
based in the uk
where they are simply learns partner and
operating in a number of different
countries so we're very glad to have you
both here today
and i'm going to start off
with
an interesting fact
um
upskilling and reskilling
to precedent in 2020 because
of the patterns that are established
before the pandemic and the exploration
pandemic
imposed on everyone in terms of
new behaviors and the need to do things
uh in a non-contact fashion
um
so
what
you both see is the biggest changes that
enterprises have had to make
to adapt to this
new reality
um
krishna i kind of lost the end of that
question but um do you want to have a
swing of this one first
yeah russell so if i got it right um
stewart what
what you meant to ask is that
what with this pandemic coming what were
some of the priorities of the
enterprises and how it how those
priorities change see from my
perspective the biggest thing that i
noticed um
and i saw like enterprises in my network
talking about is that so this was one of
a kind disruption nobody ever imagined
that something like this will happen but
i think one of the one of the like
characteristic of human race always has
been that adapting to anything new that
was thrown at the challenge that's why i
just species will survive and when this
whole thing happened i think
most industries most people
try to adapt to this new change
and i think within a couple of months we
all accepted this as a new reality that
this is the new reality now keeping this
as a constraint let's figure it out on
what we can what as an enterprise we can
do right
so
when you think about a digital and
digital disruption i think that
it was already happening before the the
pandemic also it was not something new
is just that
because of the pandemic because of this
whole new phenomena of being locked
inside your homes reaching out your
customers remotely trying to fulfill
your daily needs again remotely i think
that drove a lot of transformation for
all kinds of companies people could very
clearly see that companies which were
fully digital i think their business
started booming because people were just
logging into their internet and trying
to find anything and everything that
they could get their hands on delivered
at home and companies were fully
physical they started experiencing a lot
of challenge and and that's where they
started
figuring it out ways in which they can
also move a part of their business
online and try to survive or or
eventually thrive
this is an as an opportunity right so i
think
this the first few uh
months were a period where everybody was
like
still trying to to
accept the new reality and then people
started adapting and i have seen all
kinds of examples where companies which
were like all fully digital they have
accelerated big time
those were not digital at all they have
made at least good progress so i think
net net the
the whole impact of
pandemic was that what was already
happening the digital disruption was
already happening it just got
accelerated in a
very very
accelerated manner something that
companies never believed that they can
work that fast right but everybody
adopted and
look where we are right while we
expected the economy to do very bad and
lot of job losses and what not but if
you if stock market is one indication i
think it was never a better time to
invest in stocks than during the
pandemic so sometime it is like very
difficult to
accept the reality but that's where we
are right it turned out to be a great
opportunity for all kinds of
businesses
except a few which got really impacted
big time and and hopefully they also
find a way of coming back strongly in
the
future
yeah i agree so i think you know
adversity is the mother of invention
we've definitely seen
a huge amounts of challenge for
organizations that we work with the
disruption at the beginning was
significant um we we know that we saw
that
um
lots of organizations had to very
quickly change but as i said that
adversity became the invention that
people needed to go and do things
differently
and i think if you're responsible for
a learning organization
for an enterprise for a large
organization you would have coped with
significant amounts of change right at
the beginning and
i think one of the things to remember is
that the pandemic
didn't cause the digital transformation
that's going on it just accelerated it
but it also didn't hit everywhere at the
same time so there's a phasing issue
going on as well so we see different
organizations different countries
different locations
you know you've got a global business
houses as well we we saw the impact hit
different countries at different times
um
of course the big challenges around
customer interactions moving to online
even in traditional what might be called
bricks and mortar businesses you know
huge amounts of movement towards
customers engagement being online
we saw the acceleration of
the use of artificial intelligence and
automation lots of jobs that just used
to exist all of a sudden couldn't exist
and then
organizations found ways to innovate
around them and now those jobs don't
exist anymore they've almost been
automated out of the uh employment
system
yeah we're seeing
uh quite a big distinction between
organizations who could easily work from
home and those organizations with
frontline workers where working from
home is
not possible so you've got that at play
and i guess if you're supporting an
enterprise that has frontline workers
and work from home workers you've got to
balance the needs of both of those
core audience groups
and what we're seeing now is this sort
of real
acceleration of so many businesses yes
led by tech businesses but you know
almost all businesses now and that is
leading to some significant skill
shortages and i guess one of the reasons
we're talking here today
is this concept of
you can you hire in the resources you
need to help you achieve your business
goals or do you have to up skill and
re-skill those people within your
organization
and it very much depends on where you
are in your own growth
cycle as an organization um
but we saw
jobs lost during the pandemic and some
of those you know
low-skilled jobs may never come back
and so that that poses some challenges
going forward but i do agree with you
when we talk about digital
transformation already being underway
and the impact of the pandemic was
really an accelerant for it
yeah
okay um
that leads to
a question regarding
a survey that recently
happened and
i did a white paper based on that
donald h taylor
looked at the
1d professionals worldwide asked them
what was the
top of mind
trend
or this coming year
um this was at the beginning of 2021.
and reskilling and upskilling were the
top trends in collaborative social
learning
as a modality for that
so
um
given
that
how do the changes in digital
transformation
drive what skills enterprises require
what things they need to add to their
teams with things
that they need to deepen um
russell you mentioned ai for example
how does it also match the tools
that enterprise led uses
for upscaling and rescaling
and i've put that question into the chat
box so
i mean from my point of view there's two
things colliding here
on one hand you've got some skill
shortages that are developing
particular areas
and that's colliding
with
other areas where automation is taking
jobs away so both of those factors are
at play and sometimes the narrative
around them
is
contradictory so when i think about
skill shortages i did something this
morning i just went into google how many
vacancies have we got
uh in my three big core markets uh how
many vacancies are there
in the uk at moments about 1.1 million
vacancies how many vacancies are there
in the australian market it's about 330
000 how many vacancies are they in the
u.s at the moment 10 million vacancies
so you know just there very quick google
survey you know hands up it may not be
after it but you get the flavor for
there are you know millions of vacancies
across the world
and those vacancies are in areas
maybe that are different to where the
labour gaps that have been created by
coronavirus and the pandemic and so if
you're in
enterprise learning and you're thinking
about this challenge of i've got skill
gaps i need
more technical roles i need more program
management roles i need more
data sciences
you know but the
pool of employees that we're looking to
recruit from might not have those
because you've got that kind of problem
um
another survey i looked at recently i
think it was a mc survey
called beyond hiring
and
they said about 87 of employers are
currently experiencing skill gaps or
expect them in the next few years
so that's that's almost everybody you
know and and that's a significant thing
for us
uh to deal with
um
bishop do you want to add something
before i go into the tools and the
things that are going on
yeah russell i i definitely want to add
see one thing
completely aligned with what you said
about
automation taking away job and at the
same time everywhere you see there are a
lot of openings in what i want to add
the india angle here so as a country we
are a pop we are a country of billion
plus
[Music]
people right and if you talk to
businesses all across like all kinds of
businesses their number one challenge
today is not whether they have customers
order whether their business whether
their product and services in demand are
not most of them are talking about lack
of skilled talent and that's so ironical
right at one place in a country like
ours we talk about how can we add
employment how can we add new jobs and
at the same time there are people not
able to find enough trained skilled
manpower you know just before this call
i was i was on a call with a
uh one of the largest i.t services
contributing us in india and they was
they were talking about that if
if
they had the kind of skill talent that
they're looking at on time they can
easily add another 10 to 12 percent
year-on-year growth on their growth rate
and they're already growing at about
30-40 percent imagine a multi-billion
dollar company growing at another 10
percent on their growth rate so we are
talking about huge amount of
numbers there and i and if you take a
step back that the reason why this has
happened because of this whole digital
disruption this whole automation and
being driven by all kinds of companies
suddenly there's a huge demand of
digital talent and if everybody is
tapping into the same talent pool which
was ready before this
whole uh
transformation become a priority
obviously there's demand and supply gap
catching up and these people have become
very very expensive and at beyond the
time you can't if there is a if there
are millions of opening and there are
availabilities only few hundred thousand
there are people who are not going to
get this talent and that's where we have
seen that a lot of companies are
focusing a lot on how can they build
this talent on their own and hence this
whole learning and development and and
building this kind of talent has become
a big big priority for a lnd
professional one trend that i noticed in
a in many large companies is that many
of these companies are running lnd
function as a business function so in
the past lnd used to be a
a enabler that okay we also do l d if
you are looking at learning a
development we encourage employees to
learn and get ready for the new skill
but now it has become such a big
business priority that it is being run
as a business function and metrics are
interact very closely on how many new
people we we got into some of these
newer skills so that our our project and
product priorities are not
getting compromised
yeah i mean you look at the
skill or job role gap i think another
another report i looked at so it's only
like 150 million
new roles in digital transformation
related roles between now and 2025 so um
yeah four years
you know we're talking about a
significant amount of vacancies even if
we talked earlier that they're here
today those new roles have got in order
for organizations to meet
their growth targets those roles are
going to be filled and to fill those
roles we've got a real challenge on our
hand to upskill people to be able to
fill those roles
and
when i think about
learning a development and the
enterprise learning development folk
that i work with um
yeah they're looking at juggling
huge number of tools and platforms that
they could use
to deliver learning
um that they've dealt with the fact that
learning
used to be a blend between online
learning and physical and personal
learning and they have to shift towards
uh you know certainly during the
pandemic on what 99 or 100
virtually delivered or online learning
delivered yeah that's a big change in
the learning space um
but it's become to me at least more than
just about the platforms where there's
loads of choice for organizations it's
become about the partnerships that they
can create
learners so the customer our end
customers in the learning business are
the people who need these skills
and
you know what is happening there is also
change because
something that um
people talk about learning in the flow
of work you know learning at the point
of need when you've got that gap you go
you need a solution then and there and
so
enterprise learning teams got to think
about how do they have the resources for
their employees so that in the flow of
work they can learn
um
because
the customer the end employee who needs
learning
the skills gap will try to close they
don't want to wait a few weeks they want
it yesterday when they need it in the
flow of work um
and they do that in their personal lives
this is a big shift change it came about
because of the pandora everyone is a bit
more aware personally of what they're
trying to achieve
and
maybe maybe soulfully thought inwards
during the pandemic about what's
important to them and staying healthy
developing
living true to their values those things
become really important to people and
during that period of reflection a lot
of people came out the other side going
i'm going to develop myself i'm going to
develop some new skills for myself and
i'm relying on my workplace to help me
do that and if my workplace isn't ready
then i'm going to do it myself i might
go to youtube i might go
for different types of learning
resources but i'm going to do it because
i'm that way motivated
and i think that that's where enterprise
learning teams need to think about how
do they build
a culture for learning within their
organization
because if you can build or foster a
culture of lifelong learning within your
organization
you know you're you're on the right
direction and and i always classify that
as being able to say you know are people
focused on growth
are people trying to become
you know masters of different subject
areas not just one you know are they
being stretched out of their comfort
zone
you know are we promoting them to take
personal responsibility for their
learning yeah
are we helping people to direct them to
learn the things that they love you know
if you can if you can align somebody
behind something that they're passionate
about and provide them new skills about
that you've got you've got a highly
sort of focused highly uh valuable
employee and somebody who's enjoying
life and if you get those things right
then the objectives of how do we fill
some of these vacancies how do we get
people doing these jobs they sort of
solve themselves
so
what we we know from
the digital transformation is that
digital transformation
requires
digital skills
um
so as you pointed out this is not a new
thing it's been accelerating before 2020
got into overdrive during the pandemic
so now digital skills
are
essentially survival skills
so
the question
for you is
what do you see as the mix of skills
required
between end users of digital technology
the developers in digital business
systems
then the business skills
around the technology like project
management or marketing
that are impacted by distribution
yeah sure so
when i think about
that skill shortage i talked about 150
150 million roles
and you kind of look at where those
roles are
expected to come from
uh that'll give you some
clues to the sorts of programs that
might be needed
and the skills that might be needed but
i'd take a step back from that a little
bit and say this is you know again
advice or thoughts around managing
learning for an enterprise
learning should be
thought of as a strategic capability you
know a strategic differentiator in an
organization's value proposition
um
and then when you think about divide
designing or developing
learning programs or curriculum
you know set against those skill gaps
it's about saying well what are the
skills that this organization needs um
where are the gaps likely to be in the
future and then deciding which of those
gaps we're going to reskill employees to
fill
versus which are we going to hire in
external new talent in order to fill
them and that's where
you can you can do a time and a cost
analysis to say well which is the right
approach
if you need it super quick maybe hiring
is the right approach but maybe if you
can see
in your roadmap in your pipeline
flavor or a transformation
you can look at different ways um
and i would say
back to the you know number of different
jobs technical skills like software
development mobile software cloud data
machine learning
cyber security
um
yeah if we get if we've got this much
digital transformation on there's a lot
of project managers needed um you know
there's a huge amount of change going on
changes just projects so
you know those are the sorts of
technical skills that organizations need
to invest in
but they also need to invest in the
leadership skills
and the
softer skills that allow and enable
people to build teams and to deliver and
execute on strategies
technical skills alone will never never
allow organizations to deliver
strategies so
i'm seeing a shift from maybe
traditionally what we're called t-shaped
people you know a broad understanding of
lots of areas and real depth and
expertise in one area
towards
what people are calling m-shaped people
so three or four deep areas of expertise
as well as those those
broad
capabilities and it's that combination
which allows them to work in
cross-functional teams allows it to be
more effective so if i'm thinking about
the enterprise how do i encourage the
people in my organization to be able to
fill fulfill multiple skill areas in
overlapping areas
those are the sorts of things that i can
see and how would i blend the content
between
formal structured content and informal
say less structured content more
bite-sized content because again people
don't always have the time to do a
two-hour module or a long course some do
but not all of them do
and so for enterprise teams how do i
provide
people with small nuggets and bite size
content as
well christian do you want to comment on
that
i think
the story i don't have anything to add i
think i completely agree with what uh
the points that
russell has made so i think let's get to
the next point i think all the point i
completely agree okay uh as a
sidelight we have a definitional
question from one of our youtube viewers
asks
what is the difference between
how do we define the difference between
upskilling versus reskilling
see i think from my perspective i think
obviously these words are being used
quite uh together
in in various conversations but from my
perspective reskilling is a
is not a is there is a is an event based
on when you are working on a certain
industry certain area certain role and
based on how the whole world is shifting
you acquire a major skill so you
completely reskill from one place and
get ready for a new role so it's a very
involved process requires a lot of time
to shift from one role to another role
sometime it can be the role within the
same industry sometime it can be totally
changing the industry also a lot of
people who have changed industry very
very successfully depending upon
their circumstances so that's reskilling
one example to understand is this whole
like airline industry airline got
impacted in a big way and we saw all
kinds of reskilling be done by people
who were serving the airline industry
and they got ready for various other
jobs in in other industries which were
looking for this kind of
more or less same talent but additional
skills that made them employable and
upskilling upskilling is a process of
on continuously and constantly learning
something new so that you you you are on
top of your uh game right and cons and
upskilling need not be happen through a
formal training process while you
execute your job also you can upskill
you can watch it watch a short youtube
video and you can learn you get you get
mentored by your maybe your manager who
is trying to explain you the new role
and and what he or she expects from you
to deliver that role so upskilling is a
constant process you are doing we are
doing it all the time everyone does it
sometimes
upskilling can also be done through a
structured program but reskilling is
usually done through a very very
structured program to get you ready for
the new role
very good um
that's a clear explanation that's
actually
a clearer explanation than i want the
idea i had in mind um so russell had
talked a bit about
what the impact from home had to do and
the workforce is kind of split between
essentials the people who have to be
at work in person
and remotes who are the people
who can work from home
and as you mentioned before
this happens suddenly this happened
overnight um
but it also means that in-person
training is no longer an option
for
people who are working remotely
so
how has this impacted the way corporate
learning and development
has been structured and delivered
to the new environment
so actually uh if i get it right uh
studio saying that essentials have to
work from office and and people who are
working remotely they can work for
remote frankly i am not like uh
necessarily agree with this statement it
all depends upon the nature of the job
right so what we are
telling by this statement that if you
are working remotely you are not
effective i don't think you can make a
generic statement like that right there
are rules that can be performed
perfectly well remotely there are roles
that require being in person like for
example like if you have an operation to
perform the doctor has to be in
operations theater personally right but
if you have to like just
consult a consult a
and doctor can maybe perhaps do it
remotely to
speak and maybe come and check the
vitals later on in person right
something similar is true is true in in
in in a digital industry also like a lot
of work training customer service
handling queries all can be perfectly
done
remotely so i think the definition of
what is essential and what is not
essential is not dependent upon whether
you are working remotely or you are
working in person it depends upon the
role some rules
require in physical presence some rule
requires remote presence and the work
that is happening remotely can also be
an essential work not necessarily it's a
it says it's a second priority
yeah
work
an unfortunate choice of words that that
particular consultant used they
uh developed those terms because
essential people in their view
are the people who have to be hands-on
out in the field but
that doesn't make the people doing
remote work any less essential obviously
um so yeah i agree entirely with you
right then the question has to be
you know now that we have so many people
who are working
remotely
um
we've seen in simpler business
the impact that that's had on demand for
our services so could you comment a bit
on how that's
changed for enterprise learning and
development here's why
actually i'm having trouble hearing you
uh stewart very clearly i don't it's a
problem at my end or your end the voice
is coming in in in bits and pieces so so
question is that how it changed our
business i think um we have spoken about
it multiple times one of the industries
that got
impacted or i'll say got positively
impacted is obviously education because
a lot of training suddenly moved online
and the need for training also increased
because of various region one
certainly the demand for digital skill
in skyrocketed so a lot of companies are
looking at ways to fulfill that demand
that's also being seen by individuals
who are looking for a job they see a lot
of uh new jobs and high paid jobs are
available in this digital skills so
people are looking at how can they
reskill and get those jobs so that also
has has its own
magnifying impact companies looking to
hire this digital skilled workers and
they're doing a lot of training
intervention people who are looking for
to hive to grow to grow faster they look
they are looking at changing from
traditional industry to getting into
digital so that drove a lot of
requirement and this these are two core
uh
needs that that drove a lot of a lot of
online training in our area but there
are lot of other things also drove this
requirement
one of them was engaging employees when
when when companies realize that their
entire workforce is working remotely and
everybody is in their own different
physical spaces
training was also used as a medium
through which they can engage those
employees right and though and that also
worked as a as a very big motivator for
employees to get connected and talk
about something that not necessarily
related to their current work something
that they can upskill and write on their
resume so that was another tangent that
drove
a requirement for uh training and the
net net result is that i think it has
become a very established model now as
things go back to normal i think i don't
think one year down the line companies
are going to look at
their different ways in which they used
to train in the same manner that they
used to see before pandemic
our hypothesis is that skills training
will completely move online
will still be a leadership related
trainings that will happen in person
because there's a lot of value in
in-person interaction when you are
trying to teach some of the softer human
human
kind of skill but when you're like
trying to teach hardcore digital skills
something that you write a code and it
gets implemented something that you you
tried
you can you can learn by doing very
easily and there is only one way of
doing that i think those those kind of
trainings will completely move online to
a large extent
and the good news also is that because
of the scale this has got a part this
system has got perfected now so many
millions of people have now used this
way of learning all night that companies
have learned
re invented their model and now these
models are ready for scale
yeah i'd agree with that and i think
that we've seen
i think i think change is always
difficult for people and even though the
technology existed and the
where with all and that the
functions were there people still
resisted that change and what the
pandemic forced everybody to do for the
reasons you just outlined you know help
with the engagement etc we've got no
choice we need to deliver some training
they forced to change which then
people started to realize hey this is
not too bad so what what's the impact
for the future on the corporate
work
enterprise workplace well i'm going to
suggest things like more blended
offerings so a blend of online and
offline and more e-learning
because it works and it has now been
proven i think more partnerships with
specialists as well i think
you know some times traditionally in the
past you know a lot more have been
in-house and i can see more
partnerships becoming the norm
um
i think
not just
training programs but learning journeys
pathways um academies whatever you want
to call them everyone's got a slightly
different definition for them but you
know we're not talking about one
course
one day two day five day we're talking
about six months multiple interventions
through different channels that is what
will change
uh from maybe where we were education
so much of education and training and
development as part of education comes
from our experience as a school children
and you know
a lot has been documented about how that
is something that hasn't evolved fast
enough and is now evolving at pace
there were times during the middle of
the pandemic when in my house there were
three children on three separate zoom
cores and two adults on two separate
because really testing the wi-fi um you
know and you could imagine that that's
five different people
all engaged in some form of learning
intervention that is a very big shift
from that traditional victorian um
education model
but we're seeing that happen
and it's happening very very quickly so
teams have got to come up with that more
blended more partnerships you know the
pathways and and bite-sized
interventions
um
i'd like to share with you some of the
things that we found from
a bit of our learners
and can you hear me krishna
yeah i can hear you stood yeah
okay
um
i apologize for his technical
happens
we can look at a few things that we
asked our learners and
they asked about cavity work we asked
about categories of
course at the moment this is actual data
from our enrollments
i find that
the easiest
area is digital operations um
data science and ai
technology
um
software programming that type of thing
are both important and then there's
still the digital business
project management marketing that type
of thing
um
so when we look at these
in terms of the most popular courses on
our platform
um
saw that
there's a lot of interest in
project management in the digital
operations category
um
a lot of things
in emerging areas like cyber security
um
development cloud computing
and
data science and ai are highly demanded
and
in
marketing
so
ask people what they and we're going to
ask the audience later
what the skills
they are most interested
um
does any of this surprise you in terms
of the popularity of the skills is this
um you're seeing from enterprise clients
russell yes you first
so again i think the lines breaking up a
little bit but
from what i understand these these
aren't things that surprise me um these
are the skill areas
if you think about what we just
described in terms of digital
transformation a lot of organizations
whether you're a technology business in
the first place or you're a bricks and
mortar business that is evolving you you
have a huge number of complex
technology driven projects on the go at
the moment that's going to create demand
in the project capability program
capability space
um
in order to understand how to make the
right decisions around those projects
you're going to analyze data there's
huge amounts of data every business
every digital business has got a lot of
data but all businesses have a lot of
data um
and
instinctive management used to play a
much greater part
uh to play in decision making now data
analytics is playing a huge part in how
you make decisions as organizations
leaders really got to take that on board
but we know in our own businesses that
data just multiplies and becomes really
difficult to manage very very quickly um
and
you know a lot of people and then revert
back to instincts to make decisions and
that's that's not always the best
strategy so so no those topic areas you
highlight don't surprise me one bit and
um
it makes sense
christian talking about earlier you know
lots of people during the pandemic going
to simply learn product offerings
ideally
digital transformation
anything you'd like to add to that
question
should i have a really tough time
understanding um the the broken uh
questions so i think um
because i'm not able to yeah
i was just
i think the question was
when you looked at those findings
does that align with your understanding
of of what enterprise clients are asking
yeah so i think i can definitely uh talk
about both the areas like we see
like every year we trained about 200 000
people on the consumer side and another
70 to 80 000 people on the enterprise
sites obviously we have a lot of rich
data around what's being what uh
both individuals as well as
enterprises are looking to get trained
on and it's not surprising since some of
the biggest demand is in areas like data
and full stacks obviously they are they
are far far
way ahead compared to any other area so
a lot of data is getting created every
click is a data point i think and
companies are trying to make sense of
the data so huge huge uh
upskilling and risking that is happening
on data and just to clarify further see
data is not just one skill it's like lot
of skills that are part of data as a
domain there are people who can be data
analysts which is a entry-level roles in
dealing with data and then there are
people who become like
data scientists which is a very high-end
skill not everybody can become data
scientist but but companies require data
scientists and that's a very very deep
uh
skill required and that also requires a
lot of competency by being very strong
in mathematics and statistics and so on
then there are rules like data
engineering which is all about building
platforms related to data so that data
analysts can make sense of the data they
can easily switch data and data
scientists can do a lot of their
manipulation on the data so that's a
definitely a huge area technology again
a very big area a lot of developer
developers are needed to build the new
age digital system lot of testers are or
quality analysts are needed to make sure
that what developers are building
somebody else is testing so technology
is again a very very big area where a
lot of it is killing and upskilling
happening other areas where we see so
i'm i'm clubbing also cloud as part of
technology because now pretty much all
new development developments have moved
to cloud because cloud comes with a
ready ready-made infrastructure wherein
you can keep on adding incremental
feature on the go so these are two big
area data and technology of course there
are other areas like um
digital marketing because companies want
to
acquire customers online and it's in
general a great skill for everybody to
have and then obviously the areas like
project management quality and all there
is some growth but the growth in those
professions or those areas is not
nowhere compared to the kind of growth
that we have seen in data and technology
space
i'm not sure if we can hear you stuart
sorry about that i thought i had unmuted
myself
apologize for that um
if you could start on the slide uh by
addressing these trends and then russell
if you could
um
add color to that
so i think it was true from from my
perspective i definitely resonate with
all the trains that you have listed i
think
boot camp has definitely got good
acceptance i think boot camps used to
happen uh before the pandemic also and
it was like there are a lot of like
local boot camps in every city every in
fact every area of a city there used to
be a provider who will get
like-minded people to a physical
classroom train them and get them ready
for a new role because this technology
the whole training experience has moved
online and there the bigger players have
this
i'll say unfair advantage because their
ability to spend on technology their
ability to provide a great online
experience is much higher than a small
physical classroom provider so so this
also is becoming more like a global
business and and we get lot of we do a
lot of such digital bootcamp training
across the globe thousands of classes we
run on our platform every month so
that's definitely a trend and there are
other providers also who are who are
offering this kind of this model of
training and this has definitely got an
acceptance as a category this was a
category but it was a small time
category before the pandemic after the
pandemic this bootcamp has been digital
bootcamp has become a big category
within the lnd space for sure
partnership with higher education for
sure i think we see a lot of trend
wherein some of the large institutions
are partnering with uh
provider providers like us to launch
training program in case of simply land
we partner with the likes of mit caltech
purdue
university of massachusetts in us in
india the likes of iits which are the
real ivy league kind of institution in
the country and over time you're looking
at partnering with a lot of such
institutions all across the world
and not only us i think we see other
providers also doing
following a similar kind of trend and
the reason is that earlier higher
education institutions were very not so
open to collaborate and launch programs
but i think this has become an
a kind of unsaid understanding in the
market is that
training companies and education and
higher education institution they're not
competing with each other they can maybe
collaborate with each other to do
something that is good for the learners
so i think as that model has got
established
we see a lot of openness in in higher
education provider to do something
together definitely that's a trend and i
see that trend only
growing in future based on the
discussions that we are having with so
many other educational institutions
that we have
partnership with the industry providers
definitely i think this was that this
was this was something that was
happening even before the pandemic i
think after the pandemic it has got
accelerated because when you think about
it the demand supply gap cloud is an
area where there's a lot of demand
supply gap the top three cloud vendors
microsoft google and amazon there's a
lot of incentive for them to train a lot
of people around their technology so
that they become the adopters of those
technologies so this trend has got
accelerated but frankly this was pretty
much the train even before the before
the pandemic and role-based alignment of
skill set with employer needs i think
this is a new uh phenomena that we are
seeing
because of this
people mostly being remote companies are
looking at getting people who are at
different locations and identifying them
on what role they can work on and can
something can be done that is that is
very very custom for those
employees so this role-based learning is
a new trend that we definitely hear that
companies hire and say that hey there
are 100 people we want to make them data
analyst so not only train them about my
company's specific
policies procedures and product but also
how to do a data analyst job so we see
more and more such things happening in
the market if you go to all the consumer
focus
providers and and for simply learning a
large part of our business is consumer
focus most of the courses will be named
this way so you'll find a course that
prepares you to become a data analyst
you'll find a course that helps you be
prepared to become a full stack digital
marketer and so on because that's the
trend that we see people don't want to
learn a skill for the sake of learning
that skill they want to learn something
to get into a certain role so we
definitely see this also as a new trend
that is catching up very soon
and i i would agree with all that the
other thing i'd add is that it's it's
back to the
organization demand plan figuring out
where the skill gaps are understanding
strategically which ones you want to
train or retrain or upskill versus which
ones you want to fill through
recruitment and bringing your new talent
to an organization and
and i see that the real challenge for
people is going to be building cultures
that hold on to great employees
um getting the balance right because
there's going to be high demand for some
of these roles uh and then building up a
pipeline of new talent
comes maybe through people who are new
to your organization or at the beginning
of their careers
where you can put together learning
programs that are spread over a slightly
longer period of time but give them the
essential skills they're going to need
to fill those skill gaps you've
identified in your strategic demand plan
okay
um
so
those are great answers and that lead us
to our last poll
which relates to what our members of our
audience
see as the critical skills for their
enterprises
so about 40 seconds to answer this poll
obviously
you can select more than one skill
because
this is not an exclusive
trade-off
there's a big convergence between
product management
yeah
not always but you know
project managers
like product
and
part of the question of course is how
soon you would want
to start a program like that so let me
show the results
and in the product the project
management business skills are
the most popular category but it's a
pretty
broad distribution
and more than a third of the respondents
say they would like to
start that kind of training in their
companies right away which
makes perfect sense so
with that i'd like to move to questions
and answers
and
we have a few questions from the
audience
the first one
is
from a check who asks where do you see
the major gap
between skills requirements
and trained consultants
so if i think
if i understand that question is
how do you match up the skills that
uh
enterprise
needs
uh if people can fill those skills on a
constitutive basis
versus people who
can be trained to do that internally
yeah fine okay so so i think um
real challenges around
upskilling internal training consultants
to deliver the range of technical skills
that are in people's demand plans these
days
and so
all the big challenges around
partnerships multiple partnerships
different types of organizations i
suspect
the other thing is
building
training programs in a design it wants
to deliver it many times mentality and
that's the other solution so that you're
not
you know tying up your training
consultants uh you know to deliver
on a you know one-to-one basis or one to
a small number basis all the time
that's that that if i understand the
question is my answer
okay um
juno asks
has there been a noticeable difference
the effectiveness of moving hard skills
training
completely online
christian are you able to take that
just
so actually from our perspective so i we
don't think that there is any any change
in the effectiveness i think uh
uh we have seen the usage increased we
have seen the the number of number of
customers enrolling for such programs
has only increased
see at the end of the day it's an
individual choice like some people learn
very comfortably sitting at at their
desktop as long as there is all kinds of
support there are people who might find
getting into a classroom and talking
physically with other other participants
and instructor much more comforting but
i think when it comes to um whether the
trainings can be delivered effectively
online or not i think there is no
question to be asked there we have like
there is
data points of millions of people who
have learned effectively
it's it's a individual personal choice i
don't think it's it's it's it's whether
one model works or another model works
okay
i agree with that
personal learning styles adult learning
theories
um
come into play here and sometimes that
guides or
guides our recommendations to certain
customers
but what the pandemic has shown through
kind of forcing people to operate in a
remote way is that
more people maybe can learn remotely
you know using the tools that are now
available then probably thought so
beforehand and do it successfully
an interesting question uh
because i don't know that we would
necessarily
agree with the
premise which is
uh
is
what the steps and best practices to
learn digitally without a teacher
and how is it different from manual or
in learning and i know krishna that
digital learning doesn't necessarily
mean that you don't have an instructor
or teacher with you that
in fact
you can have that as part of digital
learning
yeah so that's the boot camp way of
learning in a boot camp is pretty much
a a cohort based learning where an
instructor is is teaching a set of
students and taking through the entire
learning journey and and there are other
models of digital learning wherein there
are videos and and you self learn right
so obviously there are different models
but now this instructor-led bootcamp
model has become quite
quite an established category it used to
happen before the pandemic also but in
the pandemic since colleges and
universities schools everything moved
online there's much more acceptance of
this model we so so we have adapted to
this new way and there's a lot of
appreciation for this new model
right
we have a question from ramachandra who
uh
asks
will respilling and upskilling help
someone who needs to return to the
workforce
definitely i think there's no question
asked right
and plus the way industry is changing i
don't think there is any other available
to continuously keep uh be on the top of
your roll right because all roles are
going through a transformation lot of
new developments are happening a lot of
new skills are getting added to the
existing roles right so unless you are
on top of the game
there's no top of the game through
constant reskinning and upskilling there
is no way to
to strive and and thrive in your role
i would say it's continuous as well so
the most important thing is to develop a
culture of learning and personal
self-development which means that you
are always learning always trying to
pick up something new but
i think it's a very it right now is a
great time to be returning to the
workplace uh picking up some new skills
and identifying or even entering the
workplace and going well i can see the
skills that are going to be in demand
and i can align them with the things
that i'm passionate about
and uh you know the next five to ten
years looks very very interesting
and if you can get that venn diagram
where the thing you love overlaps with
the skills people need um you know
you've got you've got uh you've got a
real winner there
that leads into a question
uh
tahira who asks
uh
uh uh what are the what's the importance
of an employee
themselves taking the responsibility to
for
their upskilling their upgrading and how
do they make that a systematic part of
their long-term development plan
so nobody
uh well very few people get the luxury
anymore of working for one organization
for all of their career and you might
even say
um you know that's not even the most
recommended approach but it's it's very
rare indeed so
you know
your personal learning and development
journey is something that everybody must
take responsibility for i feel very
passionately about that myself
in terms of structurally working through
it you know working with somebody else
being able to just talk out loud to
somebody about your dreams and your
ambitions is a good way of codifying
your plans and thinking and if that
person is a mentor or somebody with a
bit more experience than you all the
better um
but but definitely if you're relying on
your employer to develop your career
you're making a mistake in my opinion i
mean they may help fund it they may
point you in the right direction they
may encourage you along that journey and
i hope they do good employers will but
if you have a at least a 50 or 51 pop to
play in that if not more
uh chris you have a last question um
there's a
question from kyle who asks about
how organizations like simply learn are
using partnerships with colleges and
with higher education
and how do you
select those partnerships
and what
makes those partnerships different
from other modes of
learning or training
so um
kyle from simply run perspective see we
have we have partnered with some of the
top institutions in the world and the
reason for our partnership is that those
institutions have got built over over a
really long period of time
and they have a history of
introducing topics and history of
teaching new concepts
in a way that not everybody understands
that pedagogy so when we are partnered
with an mit and caltech they are known
for teaching some of the toughest
technology related topics and their
experts some of their professors are
authority in themselves in themselves
when it comes to those topics right so
so our idea was to like build something
that's not otherwise easily available
for people from any part of the world to
go and learn from them so we wanted to
get the best of the world to partner
with us so that we can impart their
knowledge to a wider audience all across
the world
and our our our partnership philosophy
is like very very
crisp and clear we are only partnering
with the top 10 institutions in the
world right so we're not it's not a
partnership that you're looking at doing
it all kinds of colleges and
and
higher education institution is like
very very selective and very very um
based on based on a very detailed
criteria that we do and and
there are other reasons also if i'm
partnering with mit caltech and party on
one side i can't go and partner with
institutions who are pretty below lower
in the ranking some of these
institutions will not appreciate and no
will not like their name to be taken in
the same fashion as as many other
institutions so so that's that's that's
also is there is a driver when it comes
to selecting all partnerships
okay
we have one last question i think uh
maybe russ could take this
talk about
reskilling in apps like helping someone
return to the workforce follow-up from
that user is
are there special challenges for people
who are 50 or older
all their special challenges
for people who are 50 or older
because that was a special challenge for
someone who's looking to get back into
the workforce and looking to use
um maybe skilling programs as a path in
and i think that it shouldn't be um i'm
not saying it wouldn't be in certain
situations but it really shouldn't be
um
and
you know i think the biggest piece of
advice to anyone
re-skilling and
upskilling or thinking about re-entering
the workplace is do as much work on
yourself and understanding yourself and
your drivers as you do on the new skills
that you're learning so that you
confidently present yourself
uh you know in any interview situation
and it's as much about being
balanced and structured in your own
self having that value and net worth as
it is the new skills but i don't think
age has anything to do with it um
there's a great book out there called
the hundred year life and if you haven't
read it i suggest you read it um and it
takes people through the fact that
people are living longer and therefore
they need to consider
their life over a much longer period of
time and that we'll all be thinking
about second and third careers at
different points and learning new skills
uh and getting back in the workplaces
and you know or changing tap completely
and going and doing something totally
different and it's a really uplifting uh
read so
check it out um not that i'm here to
plug it it's nothing to do with me but
uh you know i personally don't think it
should make any difference
that's very encouraging
so let me um
close out the
session by saying thank you to our
panelists
um
krishna and russell both have linkedin
profiles i have
i'm putting the
linkedin
profile links into the chat so that you
can access directly there
uh
with that i'd just like to
ask people to stay in touch with us
on our social channels at simplylearn
on facebook and twitter
and on linkedin we're easy to find after
simply learn
russell do you have such channels that
you'd like to promote
yeah if you're if you if you if you just
google
ilex group we've got facebook
twitter channels linkedin channels like
the all the usual socials you'll find us
there you might even find us on
instagram these days
okay and
again thank you both for being here and
for a very lively discussion
we will be sending a link to the
discussion recording to our attendees
and we'll also be sending a link to the
white paper that we referenced in the
presentation
so uh look for that in your email in the
next few days
and to our
attendees from india uh
join us diwali holiday and
thank you all for being here that
includes our webinar today
thank you
and have a good one bye bye thank you
very much everybody thank you
oh
you